chers amis c'est un bonheur pour ceux
qui ont fondé l'ump dès l'an 2000 et
l'union en mouvement de vous voir aussi
nombreux
c'est vrai que comme l'on dit tous ceux
qui se sont exprimés jusqu'à présent les
élections locales ont été souvent pour
notre formation politique et nos alliés
depuis 2002 marquée par des spirale de
défaites des défaites aux élections
municipales des défaites aux élections
départementales et aux élections
régionales et pendant ce temps là nos
adversaires du parti socialiste devenait
le premier parti des élus de france ce
qui leur donnait une puissance
d'organisation très utile et une
puissance d'organisation encore plus
utile au moment des élections
présidentielle et législatives c'est
cette spirale de la défaite que nous
avons interrompu aux élections
municipales
les élections municipales avec des
villes emblématiques
on a parlé tout à l'heure de limoges on
aurait pu parler dans notre région
aujourd'hui aquitaine poitou charentes
limousin de niort ce sont des villes qui
parfois depuis des dizaines et encore
plus d'années était à gauche
à cette occasion est apparue toute une
nouvelle génération d'élus d'hommes et
de femmes de jeunes qui sont maintenant
aux responsabilités et qu'ils
représentent l'avenir de notre formation
politique
la même chose
cela a été dit par martine vassal et
sébastien lecornu s'est produite aux
élections départementales aux élections
départementales
c'est aujourd'hui 68 départements qui
sont gérés par les républicains nos
alliés centristes et nos alliés divers
droite
c'est une force politique considérable
que nous devons naturellement utilisé
dans le respect des règles républicaines
mais également avec le sens de l'intérêt
de notre famille politique
je voudrais vous dire qu'il y à deux
débats c'est un peu technique pardon
d'abord un débat sur les finances
comment aujourd'hui les collectivités
peuvent elles continuer à investir avec
un état qui diminue nos moyens et vous
savez que la vie quotidienne les routes
les équipements de la vie quotidienne
sont financés plus souvent par les
collectivités que par l'état et puis
deuxièmement qu'est ce que nous ferons
en 2017
est-ce que nous serons dans la tradition
ancienne décentralisateur et des
amoureux de l'état ou est-ce que nous
serons dans la tradition girondine dès
décentralisateur que ferons nous des
36000 communes de france qu'il faut bien
sûr gardé comme organiseront nous
l'avenir des départements dans les très
grandes régions
que ferons nous deux c'est très grande
région eh bien nous allons réfléchir
pendant toute cette période
un programme politique pour notre
famille qui doit être à mes yeux un
programme de décentralisation un
programme ouvert sur l'extérieur qui
fasse de notre famille le plus grand
partie des communes des départements et
des régions de france
je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous un
excellent congrès